uh-oh what's up this is Jack Peterson I
recently finished my first feature film
which is called Sawgrass and I'm making
this video at the request of film
courage so this is just gonna be 5 tips
for your first micro-budget feature film
alright so tip number one is basically
just put in the work you know don't be
lazy it takes a long time to finish
these things from the from the time I
came up with the idea for Sawgrass at
the time I finished it basically was
three years so it takes a significant
amount of time and energy and focus to
actually finish a full-length film you
know Sawgrass was like 89 minutes long
and like I said it took three years from
conception to completion so it's really
it's not easy even if even if you make
something relatively short like I did
it's still gonna take a long time you
know I feel like my second feature film
might be a little bit of a smoother
process now that I have some experience
and I I know what it takes to complete
something but still I it's still a
really arduous process so you can't be
lazy and you just have to put in the
work even if you don't feel like it even
if it's you're having a bad day or
something
it's just required if you actually want
to finish something you know there's
there's a lot of people that start a
film or they start a novel or an album
or whatever the case may be and it never
gets done you know pretty much just
because they don't have the discipline
to see it through so that's pretty much
probably the most important thing on
this list actually is just to put in the
work and actually try and finish the
feature film instead of starting it and
then stopping and starting again a year
later because if you're not focused and
it's never gonna get done
tip number two is scale back if
necessary so when I initially finished
the script for sawgrass it was like 93
pages long and it was super ambitious
and it hadn't all kinds of live action
scenes I was going to shoot and all
these extensive like special effects
sequences that I had no idea how I was
going to accomplish and I kind of had
this 9
you've idea that I'd be able to raise
financing for this crazy thing without
any prior experience and to be honest I
didn't really pursue financing that much
because I quickly realized it was not
going to work so I decided I would scale
back and do something small so I pretty
much did a small micro budget version of
the same script and I scaled back a lot
of things and I changed a lot of the
elements around and made it more well I
put more documentary elements in there
and and I did a lot of animation rather
than live-action special effects so I
simplified it and kept the core of what
it was but I scaled it back so that I
could actually do it on the budget that
I had and as far as what the actual
budget was I didn't it was so small that
I didn't even really count
I just spent money as I needed to so it
might have been a few thousand dollars
but regardless it was a lot smaller than
what it would have been if I tried to
accomplish the original script so just
try and scale back if required if you
can get a lot of money
your first go-around that's that's cool
but most people won't so just try and do
something that you could actually
feasibly you know finish with with the
budget that you're working with tip
number three is don't be afraid to reach
out so pretty much what this means is if
there's somebody you want to work with
or if you have a question for somebody
that that you really are inspired by or
something don't be afraid to reach out
to them in some way whether that's on
Twitter or just their email or even a
phone call which is basically what I did
so you know when I first finished the
script for this thing I was just trying
to get anybody I could to read it that I
admired that could give me some actual
feedback and so the first person I
called was actually Bob Odenkirk you
know from Breaking Bad and better call
Saul and I just cold called him out of
the blue and at first he was like who
the hell are you basically and I
explained who I was and and what I was
doing and then the film I was making and
you know he he politely told me that he
didn't have time
- - you know read scripts but he talked
to me for like 20 minutes
gave me tons of useful career advice and
tons of information on how to finish a
film and and what I should do going
forward and you know he gave me a lot of
motivation that was really valuable in
actually finishing the film and so you
know just bob odenkirk remember me like
a year later or whatever it is you know
probably not but the fact that I spoke
to him and got all that information from
him is part of the reason why the film
is actually completed now another guy I
called called at one point was a guy
named Ken Levine who was the creator of
Bioshock and he's just a really good
writer and so I talked to him and he
gave me similarly tons of good advice
and you know inspiration and just a lot
of motivation to you know to actually
finish something
he gave me feedback and a short film I
made which was it's just super valuable
you know and just really amazing to get
something like that from you know
someone that I admire so yeah it just
you know never be afraid to reach out to
someone I mean the worst that they'll do
is is tell you that they can't help you
you know I mean they're not gonna be
mean to you you know I've never once and
someone that I called called like you
know insult me or tell me off because I
called them or something like most
people just want to help so just always
feel free to reach out to anyone that
that you want to work with or that you
want advice from or whatever you know
that's that's how I got Eric Panik the
brother of the Vegas shooter to you know
to help with my movie and I was able to
interview him for the movie and and you
know it was great and it's all because I
just reached out to him so that's a
really valuable thing to learn is that
there's there's no one that you can't
you know cold call or email that if you
really want to tip number four is don't
worry about festivals and distribution I
think a lot of people will probably
disagree with this but I've seen a
million people make you know
micro-budget feature films especially
their first ones and they submit to a
ton of festivals and they basically
don't get into any and then they try to
you know get a distribution deal and
sometimes they do like I was talking to
a girl recently who found some obscure
distributor to put her movie on you know
via VOD basically and she has made zero
money back from that probably no one has
seen the film to be honest with you you
know I really doubt that anyone is gonna
pay $5 to see some movie by a no-name
filmmaker with with you know no-name
actors in it so I would highly recommend
that you try and put your work out for
free early on and then you know later on
down the road then you can start
charging for it or you can you know move
on to bigger things but when you're
starting out you know you almost have to
put out free samples and then if people
like it then maybe they'll you know
they'll help you fund a bigger project
next time but yeah don't worry too much
about festivals and distribution deals
and all that stuff because at the end of
the day like what really matters at
first is just developing yourself as a
filmmaker tip number five is considered
a long-term investment and this
basically ties back into my point about
not worrying about film festivals and
distribution because you know there's
some filmmakers that take ten or fifteen
years before we're making any money off
their films so that's a common story and
it could happen to you so you you can't
give up you just have to keep making
films and you know the truth is most
filmmakers never even go on to make one
feature film and you know most of the
filmmakers that make one feature film
never make a second feature film so it's
just about getting past that and
continuing to make films despite the
lack of you know visible progress
because it's you know it's not something
that happens overnight and you have to
work it up over time and you know my
second feature film it's a little bit
more ambitious I'm going to try and
raise some more money this time and then
my third film after that will probably
be even more ambitious so it's just
something that takes a long time to you
know to to achieve basically so you have
to look at it long term but yeah those
are my five tips so hopefully someone
finds this video useful and
thanks again to film courage